do you have Hate in Your Heart for
Israel why why does that matter
as one human being to another you're
describing quite brilliantly that the
contents
of people's hearts don't matter as much
as the policies and the context of the
courts and the laws and what actually is
going on on the streets in terms of
actions but
this is also a human story
yeah and
uh
I feel like
at the core
of the situation here is
um
hate
is or maybe inability for some group of
humans to see the humanity in another
group of humans and so it's important
here to talk about the contents of
Hearts if we were to think about the
long-term future of this yeah I mean I
would be concerned actually if I didn't
feel some kind of way in my heart I
would be concerned for my own dignity
because the people who Revolt the people
who are angry the people who refuse to
live under occupation know that they
deserve better
people start revolutions not because
some kind of cultural phenomenon not
because of some kind of Desire but
because they cannot breathe because they
cannot
they cannot breathe they cannot live
they are living under excruciating
circumstances
you know Palestinians you know I don't
know I don't know how many Palestinians
have interacted with but we are some of
the most wonderful people I mean not all
of us I think some of us are you know
insufferable but most of us you know
most of us you know we're very
hospitable
um
we're very hospitable even like in the
early early correspondence between the
mayor of Jerusalem and the herzl who
wrote the Jewish State you know the
generosity through which uh the
Palestinian mayor was talking to herzl
who was plotting to take over his land
is impressive and at the same time you
know heart-wrenching um
but I I personally
think there is
there's a lot of dignity
um in negating your oppressor and I
think it would be ridiculous today today
if we like look back at junco for
example and we asked the person who's
lived under under Jim Crow
um if they have hate in their heart for
Jim Crow as if that's not the absolutely
logical and natural sentiment to feel
in Rifka you wrote my father told me
anger is a luxury we cannot afford be
composed calm still laugh when they ask
you smile when they talk answer them
educate them
so let me Linger on this is there anger
in there in your heart and does it Cloud
your judgment does it Cloud made
judgment
I don't think so I think with I think
our campaign to defend our homes was
particularly successful because
it was honest to what was happening on
the ground because it refused to follow
the strategy that we have used in our
advocacy before
where we shrink ourselves and we turn
the other tree can we try to convince
American lawmakers and American
diplomats and journalists of our
Humanity
um because we wait for the approval you
know I was 14 years old when I first uh
flew to Congress to speak to Congress
people and to speak to other European
Parliament then I at the time I thought
wow I must be such a brilliant
14 year old
um for them to have me here and you know
looking back I didn't know what I was
talking about I had
horrendously broken English
um and he didn't have any any talking
points and I came to realize that the
reason why we send our kids with their
PowerPoints to the hill
is because of the racism and the hatred
that lingers inside the hearts of
American politicians who refused to sit
on the table
um with Palestinian adults as equals
um and so we we resort to sending our
kids who will not threaten
um and who will not you know trigger the
biases they have against Muslims and
Arab people which Palestinians even
though we're not all Muslim are
racialized as Muslim
um
and this is why we emphasize uh the
deaths of women and children as though
the deaths of our men does not counter
does not matter all of these things I
think the new generation of Palestinians
is rebelling against
um I think words like you know I think
it's loaded uh it's loaded language uh
anger and angry and hate and so on and
so forth because it Miss
characterizes people and it kind of
delegitimizes them a little bit
um you know I think the real the real
anger is the bulldozer
um bulldozing through my house I think
the real anger is the 18 year old
soldier who refuses to see me as a human
being and strip searches me every chance
they get that's where the real anger
lies
um
and I'm quite honestly proud of
you know our unabashedness
um
and I refuse all to like bow our heads
or bury our heads in the sand
I think that's the only way forward
so anger whatever it is is a
fuel for Action absolutely and it has
been throughout throughout history